[Music]
one day Mars could look like this
allowing humans to comfortably live on
the planet all we'd need to do is to
terraform it but how well we could nuke
it with dropping nukes on Mars make it
easier to live there this is what if and
here's what would happen if we nuked
Mars believe it or not this is something
scientists have considered for decades
Elon Musk of SpaceX seems to think that
nuking Mars might be one of the best and
quickest options to make it a place
where humans could live the idea is that
we would explode thermonuclear bombs in
the sky over the planets two poles this
would heat up the ice caps and release
carbon dioxide and water from the poles
then the greenhouse effect would take
place it would heat up the whole planet
making the surface more habitable so
this all sounds super quick and easy why
haven't we done this yet it's because
there's a high chance that nuking Mars
might not work out the way we want it to
there are many things
could go wrong with this plan the first
problem is it's all just theory and the
theory could be wrong
that's because Mars has been losing its
atmosphere for a long time
Earth's atmosphere is almost 100 times
thicker than Mars's and if we're going
to live on Mars
it needs a thicker atmosphere some
scientists think that we could release
co2 from the North and South Poles and
this could make Mars's atmosphere more
like Earth's but a 2018 study published
in Nature Astronomy found that even if
the nukes are successful it would only
increase Mars's atmosphere to 7% of what
Earth has even if we create more carbon
dioxide in Mars's atmosphere it still
wouldn't be nearly enough to heat the
planet and the planet could seriously
use more heat since its current
temperature averages around minus 63
degrees and it would take decades for
the red planet to warm up even after it
gained the extra co2 so in theory this
could delay humans from ever landing on
Mars not only that but this assumes that
dropping thermonuclear bombs on the
planet would go perfectly keep in mind
these are nukes you know the things that
can destroy entire cities in fact the
bombs we use on Mars would be 1,000
times stronger than the ones used in
World War two if a bomb exploded on the
planet's surface instead of up in the
atmosphere some severe damage would
occur not only would it completely
destroy parts of the planet's surface it
would also cause even more radiation
another thing that would delay us
remember settling on Mars it's also very
likely that instead of warming Mars a
bomb could cause a nuclear winter this
could happen from the dust and particles
in the atmosphere caused by nuclear
explosions they'd almost entirely block
out the Sun causing Mars to cool down
even more
so nuking Mars probably isn't the best
idea and maybe we should get some humans
on the planet in its natural state
before we start trying to change it but
what if we nuked another planet like
Venus well that sounds like a story for
another what if
[Music]